right now horizon 2700 X costs $298 and
the new Intel I'm nine nine nine hundred
K costs five hundred seventy nine
dollars so at this point since they're
both eight core CPUs you can almost get
to Verizon 2700 X's for the same price
at the ninety nine hundred K so at that
point it's nine hundred K actually worth
it
[Music]
welcome to Horace hobbies so starting
off with the specs of both of these
chips the i99 a her cake comes with
eight cores at 16 threads with the base
clock of three point six gears and a max
turbo frequency for one or two cores for
up to five gigahertz and in a turbo
frequency for up to 4 cores up to 4.8
Gillard's
and an all core boost up to four point
seven gears which is really impressive
and for most people they will be able to
get it up to four point eight or 49 or
maybe even five yards given sufficient
coin the twenty similar X on the other
hand is also an eight core CPU with 16
threads but its base clock is 3.7
gigahertz and turbo frequency is four
point three kickers and in most cases
you can get an all core boost of up to
four point four grievers so on paper as
far as performance goes that's really
all that separates them point six
gigahertz the 1900 K is a bit more power
efficient at 95 watts as opposed to 105
Watts on the 20s and card X but that
really is quite minimal so moving on to
price right now the nine hundred K cost
five hundred and eighty dollars on UF
due to stock shortages and this happens
pretty much every single year last year
with the 800 K it went up to four
hundred fifteen dollars from an MSRP of
306 dollars for about two months and
prices really didn't come down till the
end of December and early January so
that same scenario happened this year
that is going to be quite a wait the
MSRP however is supposed to be 488
dollars that really isn't that bad at
all it's actually pretty good
the problem is that AMD has taken the
bar to a completely another level just
one year ago this actually would have
been a very competitive
offering became DS top-level CPU that 18
her ex could only boost up to four
carriers and it also did not come with
the stock see you cooler so just one
year ago this would have been their
clear choice but now it's rising second
generation it's a lot different
currently it would cost about two
hundred and fifty to three hundred
dollars more if you go an Intel route
being considered the CPU the CPU cooler
and the motherboard with AMD radisson
you'd be given the CPU cooler in their
box and you can go with the beat 350
motherboard which is a lot cheaper than
z3 7 years the 390 motherboards but I
really don't think that that is survive
comparison for the CPU but anyone who is
concerned the CPU has I would say a
flexible budget if you're strictly
looking at the value that you're getting
for every single dollar you spend then
clearly rise this choice and you should
definitely buy 20 some projects over the
9900 K any day of the week however for
many people I do think there is a lot of
gray area there are a lot of people who
aren't going over the top by any means
but they do want to premium set up what
I mean by this is that a lot of people
prefer that x4 70 motherboard when
buying a rising 20s and modern eggs
because they want a premium motherboard
and they're not gonna use a stock cooler
and instead they're going to buy a
liquid cooler like the H 100 iv2 from
Corsair or the NZXT kraken answer for
these people it really wouldn't matter
the 1900 K only runs on the premium 300
series motherboards because they're
going to buy a premium 300 series or for
our series motherboard and east side
anyways and it doesn't matter if the 99
trick it doesn't come with the stock
cooler because they're going to buy a
better liquid color or high-end air
cooler anyways so for these people it
really just comes down to price
difference in the CPU itself so in this
scenario if both CPUs are MSRP then the
price difference between Intel and AMD
will only be about 150 dollars which is
to look quite a big deal but there will
be a noticeable difference in terms of
performance as well now obviously the
performance difference isn't going to be
that big but here's the thing there are
always a lot of comparisons between
these two CPUs but
thing is I don't really think that that
makes a lot of sense because this CPU
isn't made to give the best value on the
market this CPU is made to give the best
performance on the mainstream platform
at a premium price now I don't mean this
for Intel's enthusiast lineup over there
I definitely think Intel's referring
people off for its really high prices
but as far as the mainstream platform
goes and the 900k I do think the price
is quite justifiable especially
considering that aimed here is charging
very similar prices for seafood that
wasn't as good just a year ago so given
all of that if you want the I $9.99
arcade and you want the best performance
available on the mainstream platform and
you don't have to sacrifice anything
else to be able to afford this then yes
I do think 900k is order for you because
in your situation your PC is probably
around $2,000 and another 150 dollars on
top of that is really not going to make
a difference in the long run also it
will probably make you a lot more
satisfied by going with nine a Mary Kay
you don't want to be unhappy every
single day with 2500 X V it's not like
the 2700 is cheap it's just a better
value than 900 K so you don't want to be
in a position where you apply this 27 X
because you know that it's a better
value but then you're actually unhappy
every day or you're like I should've
gone with nine already K so if you
really want the 9900 K then in my
opinion just go for it because while
there are other chips that may offer
better value
I think the 900 K is reasonably priced
and is a good chip and will give you a
really good performance for the next
couple of years however if we're talking
on a value basis then of course rising
all the way but either way I do
recommend that you guys waiting for
Black Friday or Cyber Monday or the
holiday season to buy any of these CPUs
because again it's just more money to
save and it's just only a month away
anyways but that's just what I think
what do you guys think do you guys think
the 900 K is worth that even though it
is on the pricey side make sure comment
down below what you guys think because I
do read out my comments I'm curious as
to what you guys think - make sure to
post your thoughts also if you guys like
me they make sure drop a like and
consider subscribing you could I can see
more videos just like this one but until
then
I'm hurry I'll see you guys on the next
one
[Music]